hey guys it's Justine and today we're
checking out the brand new magic
keyboard for the iPad this thing looks
incredible I'm so excited to unbox it so
let's not even talk about unboxing
that's just some box I am so excited to
try this thing out because I have been
using my iPad so much more than I have
ever used an iPad ever before smells
like a cinnamon roll look at that
magnetic hinge this has a full keyboard
a trackpad and it has passed through
charging via USB see on the side here
this is something that I'm so excited
about because the placement on the iPad
when you're trying to charge it and do
work is extremely inconvenient so here's
the new iPad pro let's pop this thing on
there this has the smart connector and
it's magnetic so it should just pop
right into place that's it we did it one
of the things when I was working on the
iPad review originally if you guys want
to check that out I put a link in the
description is Apple kept talking about
all the things that you can do with your
iPad you can do podcasts you could do
video editing and I was watching all of
these little commercials and I was
thinking to myself ok you're saying we
can do this but can we so I challenged
myself to only use my iPhone and my iPad
to edit a vlog and it was actually a
really great experience and from that
I've realized how much that I can do
with this that I never had even thought
was possible before and since I've been
using my iPad so much I have been
looking forward to this magic keyboard
more than ever
mostly because one it does have a
trackpad to the full keyboard which
feels incredible and this viewing angle
this is
make such a huge difference in so many
different situations because whenever
you're using this iPad case you only
have two options those options usually
work out pretty well but for some of the
scenarios that I'm going to show you
guys this is going to work out so much
better I love that this doesn't actually
touch the bottom so it really is a
floating screen and it looks so good
just take it just look at that he just
got up does it look it's good on on
cameras it does with my own eyes
let me type something it honestly just
feels like the new MacBooks
obviously the iPad has a completely
replaced my computer because I do still
use Final Cut to edit I need Photoshop
and I do a lot of stuff on there the
iPad still can't do over all of the
normal things that I would be using my
laptop for around the house I have not
even touched it really at all because if
I'm doing anything here at home I'm
gonna be editing on my Mac Pro I walk
around my house all day long just
holding this because I never know what
I'm gonna need it or want to use it so
this is me with various different
sweatpants and here's my iPad here's me
one of the things that I love so much
about the new iPad is the fact that I'm
able to use an SD card with a USB see
and I can actually take the files off
this camera right now put it into here
and get it onto my iPad immediately so
this is kind of a normal set up for me I
have footage usually everywhere SD cards
from cameras external drives and also
from my phone NAR box can also be used
wirelessly but since I have a free USB C
slot we're gonna put it to use right now
I'm using the pass-through charging
because I forgot to charge my iPad last
night usually it does have pretty good
battery life but if I'm doing some
intense editing I want to have it
plugged in while we're importing footage
just to make sure nothing gets lost luma
fusion is a really great video editor on
the iPad it feels like Final Cut but
it's on your iPad you can touch it and
now with the magic keyboard having this
trackpad I can't even tell you how many
times I've called this iPad with a
computer or a laptop it's a lot even in
the short time that I have been using
this magic keyboard I can't stress
enough how incredible it is I know the
price is a little bit on the more
expensive side especially for something
like this and an ipad accessory but it
has significantly changed the way that
I'm able to use this thing and I cannot
recommend it enough this is my gaming
setup how I've been using the iPad is
I'm using it as a monitor to make sure
that I'm still in frame and we're still
recording the gameplay it's nice because
everything is very central so I don't
have to stop playing to make sure that
I'm still recording I can also use it as
a second display so if I have like a
chat window or something open I can put
that here right now I'm just using it as
a mere display for the iMac
hello could anybody hear me where do you
guys want to drop is I'm playing solos
so I don't have anyone on my team oh
come on now I just frickin started the
game give me a second come on okay do
not even I am all alone running through
the middle I'm gonna get sniped so
quickly unless nobody's paying attention
[Music]
what does the pink mean those are the
different levels of compression what
we're going to be talking about today is
our podcast setup so we're both running
GarageBand we're both gonna be recording
using the high tonight and what's really
cool about the height mic is this will
kind of act as an audio interface so
white people are like but the iPad
doesn't have a headphone jack this will
give you a headphone jack and you can
monitor with zero latency through this
as well so it's kind of cool and then
you're gonna airdrop me your audio and
I'm gonna drop it into mine we also
could be using your iPhone so if you
didn't have an iPad you could use your
iPhones and also using the new magic
keyboard with this it's amazing because
for something like this where we are
using accessories magic keyboard has
passed through charging so we're able to
charge through USB see and since gemma
is using the old ipad actually this is
the new smart keyboard because you guys
can tell on the back of here there's a
larger cut out for the camera this the
ipad is still the same size you can use
both of these with each iPad are you
ready Jenna I am ready we've been
prepping for the past six years for this
I mean I feel like I've been prepping my
entire life for this
hey guys it's Justine and I'm Jenna
we're doing a freaking podcast I cannot
believe it yeah I do because this is the
15th time we've done this intro we don't
know what this is gonna become or if
it's ever gonna be anything or forever
gonna do it again we can always like
talk about it and see if they like it
I'll be editing this ah
light editing editing don't mess up also
there's a lot of echo in this room and
I'm well aware of it this is honestly
just a test so this is this is version 1
this is invasion it's a beta test of
small brain it is we're learning it's my
thought of a same brain seem very good I
just think I had an incredible dinner
last night I think that mug should have
this on both sides like the handle on
both sides cuz like what if another
relative relative relative relatable
Jenna's relatable another relatable
topic what is what is the what's the
name I can't even think okay anyway
either way I recycle it no you leave the
the rotten turnips out and then you get
Ian's alright I think we're done now I
sweat honestly I could keep talking
probably for quite a long time but since
this is just a test I need to put maybe
like some felt on the bottom of this Cup
[Music]
it's down to a FaceTime call with Tyler
and Jenna we're working on the video
that you guys are watching right now and
we're using this app called post-lab so
that's how we're able to remote edit so
all three of us are working on this
project at the same time so I'm gonna
call them hello it's me checking in hi
okay we're waiting we're waiting for
Tyler to to answer hopefully oh my gosh
there he is that's okay that's okay
that's okay so Jenna's gonna be editing
the podcast part Tyler has a what have
you got so far
Jenna I feel like because you were in a
lot of the podcast part so if you want
to start editing that then you'll be
able to make any changes you want and
then I'll go in and start maybe doing
like some slo-mo montages cuz those are
my favorite yeah then we can go from
there hands in 1 2 3 team to 13 this is
the realistic scenario that I have been
using for a lot I've been currently
working on my animal crossing island
trying to crossbreed flowers so I've
been using the iPad a lot to reference
and now I don't have to reach entirely
over this far to touch the iPad because
the trackpad is right here I've also
been using it a lot because there is an
animal crossing pattern tool so you can
import images it'll fix allows them and
then you will be able to generate a QR
code and then they use my phone to
import the QR code into my Nintendo app
and then I import that into my switch
into the games and then I can use it at
signs or pictures basically whatever I
want in game
case you guys forgot you can use Xbox
and PlayStation controllers on the iPad
you can also use it on your iPhone as
well so if there's any games that
support it while playing hot lava right
now let's play some basketball in here
Kimmy this we're gonna get this we're
gonna get this in nope we're not it
feels crazy that you can use an Xbox
controller to be on an iPad is so great
right now I'm using sidecar on the iPads
I'm basically using this iPad as a
second display but what I like so much
about this and I honestly don't know why
I took out was so long to make this type
of a case is I can easily adjust this
without having to move my iPad all
around but I'm still such a huge fan out
of this case if you haven't been able to
tell case keyboard whatever you want to
call it so I'm editing this video and I
have my browser window over here so on
the iPad I can use this as a second
display with all of the footage that I
have for this video I can add my in my
out points and I mean actually just
using the keyboard on my computer and I
can add that right in here I'm just
gonna add it at the end you can also
mirror the display so if I want to have
a full version of what is on my monitor
it can have it on the iPad as well
[Music]
you guys might be wondering what's
happening right now jenna is also
wondering what's happening right now I
was playing my game I looked up and I
was like oh this is a really elaborate
setup that we have right now using SAP
called Sena maker and it's allowing me
to monitor four different streams from
these three phones and iPad on the floor
and what's amazing about this is
obviously having this password power I'm
able to make sure that this iPad stays
charged while we're monitoring all four
of these streams you can use this to do
live streams or you can just record it
and then edit it later
it's app is so awesome I plan on doing a
bigger video talking about this so when
I was setting up the Maddy cam on the
old iPad with smart keyboard that's when
I realized how amazing it is to be able
to have the range of motion that the
magic keyboard has because I wouldn't
have needed to shove an extra battery
underneath the case to get that same
exact shot one of the ways I've been
using this iPad a lot recently is in my
home gyms if I can't go out and go to
group yoga classes like I used to I've
been using this a lot to do on demand
yoga classes I've also been using it to
do some instructional drills here with
my friend doesn't have a name yet but
I've been watching a bunch of different
jiu-jitsu tutorials and the new magic
keyboard is making it so much easier to
adjust the stand so if I'm doing a
different workout doing yoga or
something like that I'm able to adjust
the stand very easily and with one hand
hey Maddy we're gonna do a yoga workout
now little downward dog oh that was good
that's your tongue touch my teeth Maddy
[Music]
[Applause]
just not quite like the real thing I
just had a thought this can make a great
tripod
well not really a tripod but a kickstand
for making tik toks all right here we go
let's set a timer
[Music]
yes my best work ladies and gentlemen is
Talent Maddy come on in time that my
friends is first look at the new magic
keyboard for the iPad this thing
honestly is really cool I showed you
guys a bunch of kind of scenarios where
I would normally use my iPad and you can
still use an iPad without this but it is
enhanced the entire experience overall
one of the questions that I'm sure many
of you guys are gonna be asking is can
you use this with the old version of the
iPad and yes you can
this is the new smart keyboard on the
old iPad and it still fits right where
the camera is you'll just have a larger
sweater cut out because this one has two
cameras thank you guys so much for
watching feel free to ask me any
questions in the comments or on Twitter
because I have been using this thing
extensively over the past several days
don't forget to like this video if you
enjoyed it be sure to subscribe if you
haven't already and hit the bells you'll
be alerted when I post new videos I have
a bunch of new ones coming up for you
guys so be sure to do all of those
things and I will see you guys in the
comments and in my next video bye
[Music]